we've got to recognize that you know I
think that's unfortunate sometimes that
those who are calling for gun safety
reforms often turn a blind eye to the
reality of what's happening to families
every day in cities like that one of the
things I was getting a lot of tweets
today well you gotta ask her about guns
you gotta ask her about guns because the
general feeling you know they want their
guns basically so can you just sort of
lay out your position I think that I
stand up for second Amendment rights I
don't think it conflicts with the need I
feel we also need to have sensible gun
safety regulation I think that the fact
that we have not seen any kind of
legislation passed for a very long time
is because on one side you have people
who say there should be absolutely no
regulation whatsoever on guns and who
can own them and on the other side you
have folks who are saying that they want
to repeal the Second Amendment and they
want to get rid of guns completely and
take everyone's guns away and you have
those two extremes on both sides kind of
pointing their arrows at each other with
no real real substantive dialogue and
conversation happening with that entire
space in the middle where where we
recognize that there's no conflict
between upholding our Second Amendment
rights also making sure that these guns
are not put into the hands of those who
would seek to do incredible harm to so
what would be a sensible law that is in
Fast already because that it always
seems to come down to that although yeah
I mean that's one that that we just
passed with some bipartisan support from
the house that's sitting in the Senate
now waiting for movement you know I mean
what would it do it would strengthen
background checks yes or extend them yes
and that's where I think that was
recently pointed out the shooter in El
Paso that if that law had already been
enacted that it was likely that would
have prevented him from being able to
purchase the guns that he bought what
would you say to the people that would
say well no matter how many laws you put
in place it's the bad guys aren't the
ones that follow the laws and that we
already have so many guns
out there that yeah you can pass
whatever you want you can say whatever
you want but actually bad guys don't
follow laws and these things are just
gonna keep happening well I think
there's a few elements to this there is
some of these cases in these mass
shootings where they are going and
purchasing guns you know whether it's
from a dealer or a gun show or whatever
it is these are not people who are going
and you know buying a gun from the trunk
of a car so there's the issue of how we
can improve or strengthen our laws to
make sure that those loopholes are
closed but you're right there is a
problem with the guns and the kinds of
shootings that are happening every
single day in cities like Chicago you
know people families so is there because
Chicago has some of the strictest code
yeah no it is it is and we've got to
recognize that you know I think that's
unfortunate sometimes that those who are
calling for gun safety reforms often
turn a blind eye to the reality of
what's happening to families every day
in cities like that you know where kids
are being shot on their way to school
there's incredible violence that's
happening in some of these inner cities
that we as a country have to recognize
this is a deeper this is a deeper
challenge that we have as a country that
goes beyond passage of legislation that
is one piece of it but it is not the
only thing that's going to help make
sure that we're protecting our kids and
we're protecting our loved ones when you
hear things like the city of San
Francisco designating the NRA a
terrorist organization do you think
that's helping or or I don't think I
think that further deepens the divide
you know I I don't I don't support the
tactics that the NRA uses at all I think
that they are part of the problem not
part of the solution I think that what
we need as a country is for more
dialogue to happen between people who
feel like they sit on opposing sides of
this camp because they actually just
talk to each other I think most sensible
folks would be able to come together and
say you know when it comes right down to
it I think our goals and objectives are
probably closer together than we realize
what's your general philosophy on sort
of usage of power because one of the
things I keep seeing and
this is this has now gone on for years
but the every president uses more and
more executive actions and then what
happens is the next president just
reverses them the same pen yeah Kamala
Harris I mean everyday she's tweeting
another thing about that my first you
know they always do everything on the
table but you know first day of office
I'm gonna do this I'm gonna do that I'm
gonna take the guns with all these
things and it's like even if you want to
take all the guns away you shouldn't
want it to be done by the president just
signing a piece I agree completely
what's your general philosophy on how
much authority the president should have
and how you would govern yeah I mean the
Constitution provides some very clear
limitations on what the responsibilities
in role of the executive branches and
what the responsibilities and role in
Congress has so you look at that as the
framework to be able to make those
decisions but you also look at what
these people don't care sorry to
interrupt but do you think in a weird
way people have have sort of made the
presidency into such a king like
celebrity like role that they actually
in a weird way they almost want the
president to be able to do everything or
they don't even realize that it's just a
third of the government right and until
they want the president be able to do
everything until the presidency falls
into the hands of somebody you disagree
with and you're like hold on a second
what are you doing you're abusing your
power and that's the hypocrisy that
we're seeing right now with some of my
delt and fellow Democrats are running
for president there's they're
criticizing Trump for how he has abused
his executive power and his executive
authority and in my view in many of
those cases how it's turned out badly
and hurting people but then going in and
saying well you know what if I were
president I would do X Y & Z because you
know in my opinion this is what's going
to be good for people you can't have it
both ways it's important at a practical
level as well because you see how Trump
has gone in and much of his executive
authority or the things that he's been
pushing has been to try to undo things
that President Obama has done now agree
or disagree wherever you fall on both
sides of that that creates a problem for
the American people it creates a problem
for our economy and business it creates
a problem when you have this uncertainty
it creates a problem with our foreign
policy where things can go quickly
shifting one way or the other where it
it ends up doing a disservice to the
people it's necessary to be able
to do to respect the responsibilities
that both branches the government have
all three branches the government has
and to be able to work in a bipartisan
way to pass legislation that will be
lasting rather than something that will
quickly be overturned or repealed as
soon as the hands of political power
shift one way or the other would you try
to kick more power back to the states
because I think that's one of the things
that's been lost we literally don't talk
about it any yeah I mean we just talk
about the president coming in and this
is what I'm gonna do and yeah you know
every state will have Medicare or every
state will have this gun law
yeah or anything else I think it's an
important I think it's an important part
of this is what we're talking about the
constitutional authorities and making
sure that at the federal government the
federal government is providing those
services that the federal government is
responsible for but also looking at what
are the state's best equipped to do in
serving their people fund funding for
education use that as an example right
now in New Hampshire's I just left there
I talked to a bunch of teachers we're
teaching special education and their
education is funded purely through real
property tax now in the wealthier
communities that's not a problem and
they have a plethora of funding to be
able to provide the service they need to
our kids but in the more rural
communities there are more people living
in poverty and they end up paying much
higher real property tax just to be able
to cover the basic needs for the kids in
their schools to me that's a big problem
their kids ultimately they're not
getting the resources that we need so
that's that's a role that I think the
federal government can come in and play
in making sure that our kids are getting
their resources so you wouldn't want the
government the federal government to run
education every state per se but just
kind of fill the gaps right we're in
cases like that it's not right because
every states every States different you
know in in Hawaii for example providing
education to kids about Native Hawaiian
culture is something that's really
important to us that's something that's
important to our state but not going to
be important here in California they may
have something else that they would like
to do for kids in their state so you
know that it's it's always a balance I
think it's important to have this debate
in this conversation about the role of
the federal
and the state government that you know
again yeah we see overreach happening
too often with that in mind are you
worried that we just never talked about
cutting spending anymore or certain and
neither side well the the Republicans
talked about it never do it the
Democrats never even talk about it
anymore how would you deal with that
yeah because I don't believe in Jack's
issue I mean it's a spending issue yeah
III agree I mean this is why ending the
the wasteful war spending has been such
a central focus of my campaign because
unless we do that unless we deal with
the cost of war then we're not going to
have the resources that we need to deal
with all of these other things it's not
a situation of where you think there's
an endless amount of money and we can
sit here we can do anything we can do
everything there are limitations people
in this country work very hard and they
pay their taxes with the hope
diminishing hope these days but with the
hope that those tax dollars will be used
to serve them in the way that they're
intended what we see for so long now is
is just the opposite you see a lot of
waste and you see a lot of poor
decisions being made about how those
dollars are not going to serve the needs
of our people if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlists all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell